the figure above shows the graph of f
prime the derivative of a twice
differentiable function f on the
interval it's a closed interval from
negative three to four the graph of f
prime has horizontal tangents at x
equals negative one x equals one at x
equals 3. so you have a horizontal
tangent right over
a horizontal tangent right over there
let me draw that a little bit neater
right over there a horizontal tangent
right over there and a horizontal
tangent right over there
all right the areas of the regions
bounded by the x-axis and the graph of
f-prime on the intervals negative two to
one close intervals from negative two to
one so this region right over here
and the region from 1 to 4 so this
region right over there they tell us
have have the areas are 9 and 12
respectively so that area is 9 and that
area is 12.
so part a
find all x coordinates at which f has a
relative maximum give a reason for your
answer all exponents at which f has a
relative maximum so you might say oh
look this looks like a relative maximum
over here but this is an f this is the
graph of f prime so let's think about
what needs to we don't have a graph of f
in front of us so let's think about what
it needs to be true for f to have a
relative maximum at a point so let's we
are probably familiar with what relative
maxima look like they look like a little
lump like that they could also actually
look like that but since this is a
differentiable function over the
interval we're probably not dealing with
a relative maximum that looks like that
and so what do we know about a relative
maximum point so let's say
let's say that's our relative maximum
well as we approach our relative maximum
from values for as we have x values that
are approaching the x value of our
relative maximum point as we approach it
from values below that x value we see
that we have a positive slope our
function needs to be increasing
so
over here
over here we see f is increasing
going into the relative maximum point
f is increasing which means that the
derivative of f
the derivative of f must be greater than
zero
and then after we pass that maximum
point
after we pass that maximum point we see
that our function needs to be decreasing
this is another color
we see that our function is decreasing
right over here so f
decreasing
decreasing which means
that f prime of x needs to be less than
zero
so our relative maximum point should be
should happen at an x value it should
happen at an x value where our first
derivative transitions from being
greater than 0 to being less than 0. so
what x values let me say this so
so
we have
f
has
relative
let me just write shorthand relative
maximum
at
x values
where
f prime
transitions
from
positive
to
negative
write this a little bit neater 2
2 negative
and where do we see f prime
transitioning from positive to negative
well over here we see that only
happening once we have we see right here
f prime is positive positive positive
and then it goes negative negative
negative so we see
we see f prime is positive over here
and then
right when we hit x equals negative two
f prime becomes negative
f prime
becomes negative so we know that the
function itself not f prime f must be
increasing here because f prime is
positive and then our function
f is decreasing here because f prime is
negative
and so this happens at x equals two
so let me write that down
this happens at x equals two
this
happens
at
x
equals two and we're done